STETSON: #acking Arts is
a festival and hackathon
exploring the intersection of
art, entertainment, technology,
and entrepreneurship.
HALLWACHS: I come from a company
called Little Sun, but also
from a work of art that's called
Little Sun and a global project
that we would call Little Sun.
It's based on the simple
but astonishing fact
that 1.6 billion
people in the world
don't have access
to electricity.
The sun goes in the
top here, and then you
have the little lamp
that shines in the night.
You can take it traveling.
You can take it walking.
You can take it everywhere.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Some people adopt it as art.
Some will take it as design.
Some will just
take it as a lamp,
and others will take it as
a symbol of positive access
to energy.
It's about emotions,
beauty, and participation.
AZEEM: What parts of Africa have
you been already operating in?
HALLWACHS: We're operating
in Ethiopia, Kenya, Uganda,
Zimbabwe, Senegal,
and South Africa.
LUNG: With a hackathon,
you get a chance
to go to work in something,
change it, see it
in a different way.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
AZEEM: Make it simple.
Simplicity's crucial.
The idea should be like
an elevator pitch, right?
SPEAKER 1: Oh, wow.
AZEEM: Whoa, look at that.
SPEAKER 2: I like that Little
Drop-Little Sun connection
there.
There's really striking.
LUNG: We pass water
through a tube that's
exposed to the UV light,
and it basically cleans out
all the bacteria in the water.
AZEEM: You can see that water
is kind of going this way.
So you have the two LEDs,
and you have the LED
that kind of powers that.
KOVACIC: What we're
proposing is a community
that's centered around
a website that's
going to help the people
who are involved in selling
and distributing Little Sun to
do three things-- to explore,
to connect, and to join.
OSMUNDSEN: We ended up
having a pretty even split
of entrepreneurs,
artists, and engineers.
We started out with just totally
bouncing off ideas and going
super divergent, and
then whittling it down,
and now we're finally
getting into actually
building a prototype.
PRESENTER: But how amazing
have the last two days been?
Are you guys having fun?
[CHEERING]
HALLWACHS: I'm really curious
to see the community-based idea.
Because that could be
an interesting part
of exactly this.
The communication is
really a vital thing.
TANG: Hi, everyone.
My name's Chris.
TROEIN: I'm Maria.
TANG: And we are part
of Little Sun Community.
This is a platform which
connects vendors to one another
to allow them to explore,
connect, and also join
a community.
Have you made art
with Little Sun?
Have you found a practical
use for Little Sun?
Or have you found it a cool
way of making it your newest
fashion accessory?
SPEAKER 3: A lot of those people
in those very same communities
need something else.
They need clean drinking water.
This is Little Drop.
It's a solar-powered LED
water treatment device.
The straw spools through some
germicidal UV LED light bulbs.
What the Little Drop
provides, like Little Sun,
is an emotional experience.
HOWARD: So you
differentiate yourself
from the ones that are on
the market by-- it's more
of an emotional connection?
SPEAKER 4: Have you ever
heard the light of the sun?
[TONES PLAYING]
So basically, we're
hearing the light.
FELDMAN: Transforming that
into an audio device, something
you just did, like
over the last 48 hours?
SPEAKER 5: It's, like,
extremely simple,
directly wiring a hook-up
to this headphone jack.
STETSON: The thing I find really
impressive about hackathons
is people really
kind of come in,
and they're just--
they're so completely
open to making totally
new connections
and then spending a lot of
time working on something
with someone who they just met.
HALLWACHS: The prize goes to
the Little Sun Community team.
[CHEERING AND APPLAUSE]
PRESENTER: Thank you for coming.
[MUSIC PLAYING]